what's for dinner there's meat
vegetables
and eat chicken food if you eat one
piece of kale
i will give you ten dollars i'll tell
you what my dad used to tell me
finish your broccoli or i'll shove it in
your mouth
50 bucks you eat a piece of kale don't
tell your mom about this but when you go
to school
you just sneak it right in there
just like that come on eat your
vegetables
i'm the kale elf oh will people notice
they'll notice 100 bucks and you can
sleep in our room
we'll sleep in your room we meet son
meat
200 bucks i sign over the deed for the
house
you gotta talk to your kids like you
talk to adults that's how you get them
used to the world
you're so stupid oh okay 500
you get the whole house we fund your
life and
i actually eat the kale deal
you just gotta know how to work it with
the kids eventually
they'll find a place where they give in
and look what just happened
he gave in you're pretty dumb
but you get a great personality let's
lean into that
now these are dinosaur nuggets now if
you don't like those i can stack them on
top of each other and make
building nuggets i'm not insulting you
i'm telling you what you're good at
which is
basically nothing now if you don't like
that i can juggle them in the air and
make them bird nuggets
now if you don't like that i can slide
them along the ground
like they're hockey puck nuggets if you
don't finish that broccoli
you know what's for breakfast broccoli
do you know what's for lunch that
broccoli
guess what it'll be for dinner tomorrow
or broccoli
no devices at the table buddy no ipads
no don't tell me this
is that your laptop is that a baby
squirrel there's no baby squirrels at
the table
are you gaming right now are you buying
something did you just order a
refrigerator for your room
i am big into nutrition it's important
that you make sure
that you get your vitamin c how did you
get my credit card you need some money
to buy an expansion pack on call of duty
this vitamin c fights against colds
makes you smarter
it makes your feet grow you finish that
one piece of broccoli
and i will buy you an expansion pack you
gotta eat lots of bread
bread is the most important thing bread
bread bread
bread you want to grow up to be big and
strong bread
why do they call it wonder bread if it's
not great for you
duh oh okay i'll finish the broccoli
and you get the dlc how about that for a
deal
see deal maker extraordinaire you just
got to know how to talk to your kids i
know twinkies get a bad knock
and they say oh they never spoil exactly
isn't that what you want in your food i
don't want this food that goes bad in
three days
give me the food that i can forget about
for five years
and then give to my kid and have him
still eat it
can you put that phone down are you
making a tick tock you do the broccoli
dance you eat that broccoli
people like the fun dumb guy you can
work at a carnival you could probably
work
at a pizza place dumb nugget okay does
that make you happy to call me dumb
nugget dumb no good idea
i'm not dumb no okay it's important your
kids feel free and confident
to just say whatever they want to you
you could wash dishes
you could deliver newspapers dumb
nuggets getting the food
dom no good i'm dom nugget hey buddy
time for dinner
guess how many times you get called for
dinner once
guess what happens if you don't come
once you don't get dinner
dinner's ready buddy if you want to hop
off the xbox and no you don't want to
oh i should shut up okay
he feels free to tell me to shut up he's
very confident in that and i don't want
to take away his calm
no i heard you i'm shutting up he didn't
want me just doesn't want me talking at
all
you know what's for dinner what i put on
the table
this is not a diner this is not a
drive-through i am not getting paid to
be your sous
chef and then you get your dessert you
see it's it's all about doing the dance
broccoli dance you read the broccoli
dance